why most people fail at screenwriting I
think most people fail at screenwriting
because it's the most difficult craft in
the world you know people talk about all
I want to be a director directing is
very difficult challenging job but it
doesn't compare to right craft of
storytelling most complex craft in the
world takes a lifetime commitment to
master it
now a lot of writers either don't
realize that it's going to take a
lifetime of commitment or they don't
want to face a lifetime of commitment
that's a lot of work and that's a lot of
time most writers are looking for the
magic bullet and which is why I talk
about this in my class all the time most
writers start off with this three act
structure way of looking at storytelling
which is was designed for beginners and
does not work at the professional up the
reason it's so popular is because it is
a kind of magic bullet says it's not
that hard well we'd all like to think
that writing a successful screenplay can
be done with a few simple steps you know
paint-by-numbers approach unfortunately
it doesn't work you have to be able to
put in work and you have to also realize
that the level of training the type of
training is required to get to a level
of excellence and that means literally
hundreds of craft techniques that have
to be mastered I will always tell
writers in my class you know plot is the
most underestimated of all the major
writing skills most writers know the
importance of a good main character they
know what the
importance of the lien dialog and so on
when it comes to plot they think well
I'll just figure that out as I go and of
course that never happens because it
turns out that plot has more techniques
that must be mastered to becoming
working professional than all of the
other major writing skills combined if
you don't know what those techniques are
you have really no chance of working at
that level so that's why I say that it's
so important to writers to get not just
get trained but at the right kind of
training so that they are working at the
professional level and one of the what I
think one of the key hallmarks of what
I've tried to teach in all my classes is
that professionally professional writers
use fundamentally different techniques
than all of the writers if you don't
know what those professional techniques
are you cannot play in that game you
cannot compete at that level do you
think - a lot of people don't realize
that their temperament is not suited I
mean you're spending a lot of time alone
you're having to be sort of self
generating and maybe people don't
realize how difficult that is you're
absolutely right I I consider the
psychological element the biggest
obstacle to writers success because the
difficulty of what you just said the
difficulty of facing the page by
yourself being in that room alone trying
to meet that challenge day in and day
out is very difficult on the human mind
and writers first of all don't realize
what it's going to take psychologically
at first and then when they get into it
and they try to deal with that they they
really don't have the tools of the
support system to be able to be in it
for the long haul I often tell writers
the people who work professional are the
people who are still staying
everybody else was they were knocked out
because for various reason they didn't
get the right training but but most
often it's they cannot handle the
psychological difficulty of what it
takes to write at the professional level
meaning writing alone facing rejection
again and again over many years and so
on into you have mastered the craft at
the at the level that somebody says hey
you're a good writer this is a good
script I'm going to hire you so it's the
people who a commit to the craft and B
who are still standing who are there
after many years so that finally
somebody says yeah you've done the work
you're actually pretty good because keep
in mind most people don't know a good
story they don't you know they just know
I like it or I didn't like it but
they're not trained as writers again
it's the most complex craft in the world
so part of the difficult psychology is
how do you get over the fact that you're
getting rejected from people who don't
know what you do that's very tough to
face so which do you think is more
important stubbornness or a teflon
personality where rejection just doesn't
define who you are I would say neither
of those I would say both of those are
dependent upon a previous requirement
which is me maintaining an openness to
learning the craft I will often get
professional writers to take my class
and when I talk to them what I always
find is these people have no ego at
least no ego that that is coming across
that I can see because they're
professional writers so you would think
well they think I already know this
stuff but they don't they don't take
that
attitude yes they're extremely well
trained they get to the level of
professional writer they're extremely
well trained but these are people who
are open to learning more and I find
that is the most important quality for
being a successful writer the being the
willingness to learn from anywhere
anyone so that your repertoire your your
arsenal your set of tools is constantly
grown that in turn gives you the
confidence to say that person didn't
like my script but I know that it is
based on these craft elements that make
for a good story so whether they liked
it or not that doesn't affect me I know
it's a good story that's where you get
the foundation of confidence that you
need to get through those tough
psychological moments so almost as if an
attorney or a doctor needs sort of
mandatory continuing education artists
somehow think maybe they're immune to
that like I've already learned what I
need to learn you most do most do and
it's a huge problem you know the when I
give class is the most common question
is all about how do I sell my script
they wouldn't know there's an
implication in that question which is I
already know how to write a good script
the only thing I'm not able to do is
sell it not so 99% of writers you know
they will always talk in a Leawood about
it's all about the connections all about
whom you know it's so overrated 99% of
writers when they finally meet somebody
who is a useful connection they don't
have the story tools to make that
connection pay off then we have the
craft foundation so it's all about you
know this this ability to treat writing
as a
profession and part of that is I can
never know enough about how this craft
works and partly that's because every
story is different
I talked to professional writer friends
and we're always amazed we think ok it's
going to get easier now it doesn't it
gets harder because the better you get
the higher you set the bar for yourself
on your script
Evaristo cracking a story is always hard
no matter how much you know because
every story is totally unique yeah there
are certain elements that you can use
that you can hang your hat on you can
you can get it a way into the story and
so on but everyone is tough so that's
why this is having this professional
approach to being a writer being a
storyteller it is so important it's the
only thing that eight makes you
successful but begets you through
you